welcome to this video playing bagel
heads and and he really won this game
against me in the dim zone just a couple
of just two games ago and I really want
to get some revenge them we didn't like
it that much the way that game went
so some Trump London kind of hybrid
system here let's see what Y is doing
Queen see one maybe
really had many alternatives Quincy two
runs in to see for all that looks wrong
dc5 Queen be too hard to believe so what
is their queen bee three is just good
for black because of c-4 so what is the
deal here
it disconnected or something no
well we know from the game before that
is constantly playing with some
technical tricks them so never know what
kind of weird thing yeah something weird
and yeah okay it's not working at all
objectively speaking but it's a it's a
blitz game
so what does he want to do I mean that
it be two and then what if all our I
don't quite get it
probably some kind of be four bishops II
to Queen B to e4 maybe
he's taking that he's taking ages what
is that the weird game
yeah I think I should try to get get out
of the out of the center quickly so e
cigs Bishop e7 castles you want to do
what to grab more stuff yeah unless he
and forces me with Ruby one night takes
is not stupid actually 9423 now headed
then 96 at the end I don't want that so
probably he takes it takes us better
keep the night on digital passive
Bishop c4 I can actually castle if I
like and then take c 3 even though i can
probably take the piece i don't really
believe that Kate this sacrifice okay
this I would definitely have to take 25
can take you five each was hanging yeah
I've got 23 there look you 123 it's
really nothing going on
so now I'm canceling here right 194
let's let's let's I mean we know that as
I said he's playing for for silly tricks
down 90 for some Luke is seven or
something ok 9696 is actually almost
possible anyway I'm castling here I'm
canceling him I saw that he's getting
something back here but the resulting
end game is pretty good queen bee three
cd3 Rudy seven we should be six what c5
actually maybe c5 bishop t6 ok so let's
go Bishop him white resigned his down to
something I mean that was a weird game
with his time time spent or you that
early on in the opening so completely a
standard type of position yeah here just
Quincy one or I mean even be three seems
kind of playable and this is just not
working I mean so let's consolidate you
went to e4 yeah okay the engine just
takes you three days completely without
any mercy but and I want to develop and
castle and those both sacrifice don't
work I saw this one and I didn't think
that could work check here no that's not
that's not enough here that that really
should should win somehow Queen B 2 and
you should be six also to swing yeah
okay I just wanted some wanted to make
sure i'm not getting made an end
this end game is still a clear advantage
plus the time situation so I just wanted
to avoid some kind of silly silly mate
running into this weird game thanks for
watching